[inaudible].
I get a lot of questions about
automation and delegation.
What should you attempt to automate?
What should you attempt to delegate?
The technologies change.
They adapt and evolve very quickly,
so the tools in the toolkit will vary,
but if you understand the principles,
then you can choose the tools and you
can certainly do homework to find the
latest and greatest.
I'll tell you how I look at this in the
simplest form and one of the frameworks
should sound familiar. If you've read
the four hour work week 80 20 analysis,
I will look at, and I do this
in fact instead of for instance,
New Year's resolutions, I do a review
of my entire calendar previous year,
week by week four.
In this case,
we just came into 2018 I'll look
at 2017 and I will make a list.
In fact,
two lists of the the 20% of people in
activities who produced 80% of my peak
positive emotional states.
That's one list.
The other side of the 20% of people or
activities that produce 80% of my peak
negative emotional states and it could
be as simple as frustration and what this
will help you to put together.
It doesn't have to be at the end of the
year is a to do list or I to focus list
and then a not to do list.
All right,
and I tend to focus on these days at
least taking disagreeable tasks or
distracting tasks and first trying to
automate them with software autopay,
whatever. It might be a repeating
schedule with a task rabbit for instance,
for fiscal pickup or anything like that.
Perhaps you do that through a ups store
that scans and the emails or documents
or earth class mail use technology
whenever possible instead of a brute force
with humans.
Right.
Even if they're humans involved in
conjunction with the technology,
so I'll try to automate
as much as possible first.
Then if we're looking at delegating, which
frequently includes technology, again,
I'll try to remove the
negative as much as possible,
especially with repeating tasks
that is the lowest hanging fruit.
Then I will look at my primary
projects for a given period of time.
And if you have,
let's just say four or five projects
you could pursue or that are in play in
your life,
I will,
I will narrow it down by asking which
of these projects if moved ahead to the
next milestone or if completed will make
all of the rest either irrelevant or
make all of the rest easier.
And I've done this in fact
recently in the last week,
then we have a primary focus.
This is the lead domino that
will make everything else easier.
I will throw as much at that as possible.
So let's just say hypothetically
we are trying to design a website.
Uh, in some cases you want
to throw money at a problem.
It doesn't have to
necessarily be a lot of money,
but throw money at a problem
instead of time times nonrenewable.
So I will say go to 99 designs and get
50 different submissions to brainstorm
ideas for a potential website higher,
perhaps two firms and have them all at
the same time working on designs so that
I can save time and move this project uh,
ahead as quickly as possible with as
few stops as possible. If for instance,
I need a legal opinion. All right,
well I'm going to look for a consensus.
I'm going to look for gaps to
be filled by different people.
I will very frequently have two or three
people work on that at the same time
and then gather the responses again just
to quickly review the not to do list
based on the 20% of activities and
people that tend to produce 80% of my
negative emotional states.
And then the to do list based on
looking at your list of projects and
identifying the project that will
make it the others either irrelevant
unnecessarily to do or easier.
That is the lead domino.
And then I throw as much
as possible at that, uh,
which does not need to
cost a lot of money.
And certainly for me has not caused
a lot of money, even when I was,
I'm not gonna say in the poor house,
but really,
really scraping by and very little.
You can still find ways to do it
because there is talent with overseas
domestically end.
There are many different types of software
that can help you to smooth out and
simplify process to make
a much more elegant.
So those are a few of the ways that I
think about automation and delegation.
Good luck.